a lot of different venues in space where
you can transplant sport often when
people think in space they think in a
weightless environment but that's not
realistic
what's more realistic is playing a sport
say football on the surface of another
planet
and that would have different gravity
and we have different gravity than
certain things that are familiar to us
would have to be readjusted so you would
hit a baseball farther you could throw a
football more you can if you're on a
planet that's rotating quickly then
projectiles get deflected left or right
depending on which direction they move
and depending which way the planet
rotates it's called the Coriolis force
it's what creates the circulation of
storms on earth why all storms rotate
counterclockwise in the northern
hemisphere and that phenomenon can
affect projectiles in sports
if the stadiums are large and the ball
is airborne long enough so also if you'd
play a sport on the moon is that is the
matter of like they need air to breathe
so they'd have to have oxygen tanks with
them while they were running and
performing so there are some planets
where they would have higher gravity
than Earth for example which means
everything weighs more so if you're at
the bottom of a tackle pylon then
everyone will weigh more than they would
on earth and you could just get crushed
you just get flattened at the end so
they have to limit how many people pile
on to a tackle so you know kill each
person who captain's ball little thought
that you say
[Music]